the season 2 finale of you surprised
many fans with a shocking revelation
that changed everything for Joe and
loved
however buried deep within the new
season is a secret second twist and
hidden homicide that only some hardcore
fans have noticed yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers I'm John and in this video i'm
revealing evidence of a secret murder
that almost everyone missed in the
latest season of you there will of
course be spoilers ahead so take care if
you're not all caught up
season 2 surprised many viewers when
they discovered that love is like Joe a
serial killer with dangerously obsessive
tendencies who not only killed her
family's au pair but also murdered
Candace and Delilah but there's another
character whose death remains shrouded
in mystery and that's loves late husband
James
when love tells Joe she became a widow
she explains that her husband was ill
but is vague on the details he got sick
and they they tried to figure it out but
they did not there's already something a
little suspicious about how love mostly
looks down and avoids eye contact with
Joe as she tells him this but in the
sixth episode we get numerous flashback
scenes that reveal a lot more about
Love's dynamic with her spouse when she
proposes to James that they try for
children he doesn't seem keen on the
idea and in another flashback he argues
with love that they can't afford to
raise children without taking money from
the Quin family which is something
they'd seemingly both agreed not to do
we can see from loves reactions in these
scenes that James is reluctance to have
children with her was very painful and
that's also something she alluded to
while talking to Joe my husband hurt me
too among other things by dying ever
since she killed Sofia love has been
driven by desire to create her own
perfect family but families don't heal
from something like that so I began to
fantasize about a new one but when James
broke the loves heart by refusing to
have children with her I think she
plotted to get rid of him for example
just look how much love relates to Joe's
reasons for killing back yeah you did
some terrible things but that's what
sensitive people do when they're trapped
in a bad relationship so we have a
motive for love killing James but how
did she do it
well given she's a skilled chef cooking
would be a likely way to put a plan in
action and as she explained leukemias
how expressive are we saw how love baked
a cinnamon bun for Joe that was made
with salt rather than sugar after she
discovered he lied about his real
identity at that point loved still saw
potential in Joe's a future partner
father to her children so she didn't
full-on poison him instead she made him
a foul tasting cake as punishment and
perhaps also a warning by contrast when
James ruined love's hope of ever
creating a family together she probably
decided to get her own back and really
make him pay and because love already
knew what it took for Sofia's violent
death to be covered up she may have
tried to kill James in a more subtle way
that wouldn't raise as much suspicion if
Fleur found a way to poison James very
slowly so it was hard to detect then it
might explain the fact that nobody ever
discovered exactly what was wrong with
him in fact she even referred to James
detoxing in one of the flashbacks just
detoxing which could be a wellness thing
or could perhaps hint at him having a
background of alcohol or drug abuse
something which would also provide
plausible cover for his becoming sick
and of course if there was any suspicion
by doctors or the authorities then it
wouldn't be hard for the Quinns to cover
it up just like they did with Sofia love
wouldn't even need to purchase any
poisons that could be traced back to her
because as a chef as well as someone
heavily involved in the wellness
industry and running a grocery store she
could well know that the seeds of
numerous fruits like apricots cherries
and peaches naturally contain cyanide
compounds with an average produce and
kitchen at her disposal love could
easily grind up small amounts of fruit
stones and blend the powder in with
James's meals to slowly administer small
quantities of cyanide that would make
him sick perhaps it's even a little tell
that love users of peaches her
introduction to Joe do you think the
speech looks like a boat and it's
curious how love reacts when Joe is
hesitant to eat the muffin she brings
him to eat while he's in the cage
because would you're afraid oh no
poisoned Joe as Joe and leather
basically a mirror image of each other
Joe might well be thinking of what he
did to Benjy or what love did with a
salty burn but that moment is also
drawing our attention to Love's ability
to poison her Viktor
okay the poison theory may be plausible
but you might ask why was love so
visibly upset and angry at James for
hiding the fact he knew about his
illness for eight weeks before he told
her well it's worth remembering that
although love and joy are both serial
killers they each seem to react
differently when killing someone Joe
seems to be much more dispassionate and
cold-blooded whether he's killing on
purpose or accidentally but each time
we've seen love murder whether it be
Candice Delilah also fear she's been
angry and distressed so even if love
knew she was the reason James's and well
she could be simultaneously upset but
determined to go through with the deed
because of her own warped obsession with
raising a family we can see this when
she explains to Joe why she killed
Delilah she actually believed I wanted
to hurt anyone I hated doing that to
Delilah it was I could not let this
destroy a baby's life my whole life I've
been doing what it takes and all the way
back in the first episode of season 2
love makes an interesting connection
between the death of our husband and Joe
ever since it happened I mean I'm gonna
see this thing in people you've been
through it I see that every time I look
in your eyes love later finds out that
Joe killed back and if she sees the same
in Joe as she does in herself that's a
big pointer that love also killed the
one she loved James basically both Joe
and love fantasize about a perfect
partner or family and when their loved
one fails to fulfill that fantasy they
kill them some fans have also tried to
connect Delilah's death with James by
suggesting that she had begun to
investigate James's death along with
Henderson's they pointed to the board of
information Delilah was using to write
her article about Henderson and said
there's a picture of James on there now
I checked the scene myself and I can't
see any such picture only a newspaper
cursing mentioning Henderson's cancer
and a photo of him that you could say
resembles James a little there is a
mention of a James on an article to the
side of that the articles cut off but
the title seems like it might be about a
film executive and it talks in the past
tense about a certain James who appears
to have worked in the entertainment
industry
if this is loves deceased husband James
then it's possible she met him through
forties attempts to break into the movie
business so given what love probably did
to her husband there's a chance she'll
try to kill Joe as well especially if
she catches him creeping around their
next-door neighbor maybe she'll start
slipping something into his food and if
Joe uncovers the truth about what
happened to James
he'll very likely run for the hills if
you've got any season three theories be
sure to leave them in the comments below
now do you think love killed her husband
James there's a poll for you to vote
just tap in the top right to cast your
opinion and also to see the results next
half left to discover all the Easter
eggs and other killer details you might
have missed in season two or tap right
for another video you're sure to LIKE
and if you enjoyed this and a thumbs up
and a share are hugely appreciated
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PKA movie lovers